Well, it seems there's definitely a relationship between these.
the massive point seems to move as page load time increases. I'd say--yes, they are related.
They don't really appear to be linear though.
If I draw a line to try and fit this,
I can do okay for one piece of this but then this piece over here
doesn't appear anywhere near that line, or I could possibly draw a line like this
that's consistent of a lot of range of points, but this appears to be pretty far away.
Definitely not linear and not exact either. You can, say, pick this value.
We have a whole bunch of different click-through rates for the same page load time.
Now, is the relationship positive or negative?
Well, we started off with a higher click-through rate over here.
It seems the only going downward as page load time increases, so we have a negative relationship.
When in fact, the relationship probably looks something like this.